So now, I did the hard part for you. Now, it's time for you to tell me what
these values should be. That most likely contain the true population mean if all
the people in our Klout population were to start using Bieber Tweeter. What
would be our interval estimate that most likely contains what this population
mean would be if everyone in our Klout population started using the Bieber
Tweeter? So, figure out what this is and this. And just a reminder, here are our
population parameters, the mean was 37.72 and the standard deviation was 16.04.
And then, for our sampling distribution, the mean was 37.72, like you learned in
the last lesson, and the standard deviation is the standard error, which is
sigma divided by root n Which we found to be about 2.71